lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
expresar de distintas formas el área de
este rectángulo grandote que está
compuesto de estas seis áreas diferentes
y bueno hay varias formas de expresar el
área de este rectángulo pero una de
ellas es tomar el alto del rectángulo y
multiplicarlo por el ancho del
rectángulo así es que pensemos en cuál
es la altura de este rectángulo sabemos
que de aquí para acá esta distancia mide
de cuadrada y también sabemos que esta
distancia de aquí mide menos 6 por jeff
y aquí yo sé que tú puedes estar
pensando que como puede ser que una
distancia sea menos 6 que no se supone
que las distancias todas son positivas
-6 puede ser un número positivo si es
negativo por lo que tiene todo el
sentido del mundo decir que esta
distancia es menos 6 y por lo tanto la
altura de todo este rectángulo es de
cuadrada de cuadrada menos 6 menos
y lo podemos ver por aquí la altura es
de cuadrada más esta distancia de aquí
pero esta distancia de aquí es menos 6
entonces la altura es de cuadrada más
menos 6 pero pues eso es simplemente de
cuadrada menos 6
esa es la altura de este rectángulo y
ahora cuál es el ancho de este
rectángulo bueno pues es el ancho de
este rectángulo morado que es 3 d
cuadrada más el ancho de este rectángulo
amarillo que es menos 2 ya que por
cierto aquí esta distancia también puede
ser menos 2 por la misma razón por la
que no hay ningún problema con que
tengamos aquí un -6
nos falta también sumar el ancho de este
rectángulo azul que es 1 por lo tanto el
ancho es la suma del ancho de estos
rectángulos o sea es 3 d cuadrada menos
12 menos 2 y más 1 más 1 y así tal cual
lo que acabamos de escribir aquí nos da
el área del rectángulo completo que nos
da el área de todo el rectángulo ahora
hay otra forma de sacar esta área y una
pista acerca de cuál va a hacer esa otra
forma es el hecho de que hayamos
dividido al rectángulo completo en estos
otros seis rectángulos de diferentes
colores y el hecho de que tengamos las
dimensiones para cada uno de esos
rectángulos y por lo tanto podamos sacar
su área
y ya que tengamos estas seis áreas
podemos sumar las todas pero bueno
vayamos por partes
empecemos por aquí con el área del
rectángulo morado el área es altura por
ancho entonces tenemos la altura que es
de cuadrado de cuadrado por el ancho que
es 3 porque cuadrada 3g cuadrada que es
igual a 3 x ya cuadrada por ye cuadrada
o sea que a la 4 bueno ahora vamos con
el área del rectángulo amarillo la
altura es cuadrada y al cuadrado y el
ancho es menos 2
así es que multiplicamos por menos 2 y
esto es igual a menos 2 porque al cubo
ya al cubo y con el azul pues el área es
altura por ancho la altura es de
cuadrada y el ancho es 1
el área es simplemente cuadrado y ahora
vamos con el verde la altura es menos 6
y por el ancho que es 3 porque cuadrado
3 porque al cuadrado que es igual a
menos 6 por 3 es igual a menos 18 y
porque al cuadrado es al cubo y el área
de este rectángulo gris es altura por
ancho
la altura es menos 6 y por el ancho que
es menos 2
y menos 6 por menos 2 es 12 y jr porque
es cuadrada y finalmente el área de este
rectángulo rosa es la altura por el
ancho
la altura es menos 6 g
la multiplicamos por el ancho que es 1 y
nos queda menos 6 y ahora sí si queremos
el área del rectángulo grandote lo único
que tenemos que hacer es sumar todas
estas áreas de los 6 rectángulos
pequeños y eso es igual a 3 porque a la
43 porque a la 4 menos dos porque a la
tres menos dos porque a la 3 massieu al
cuadrado más que al cuadrado menos 18 y
al cubo menos 18 y al cubo las 12
cuadrada más 12 y cuadrada y finalmente
menos 6 menos 67 y esto de aquí si es
una expresión del área de este
rectángulo pero lo podemos simplificar
más
por aquí tenemos únicamente un término
de grado 43 porque a la 4 entonces lo
podemos escribir por aquí y cuántos
términos de grado 3 tenemos por aquí
pues tenemos menos dos por ya la tres y
también tenemos menos 18 porque a la 3 y
si sumamos estos dos términos cuentas ya
la 3 tenemos pues menos 18 más menos 2
nos da menos 20 menos 20 y a la tercera
potencia y ahora cuántos términos del
segundo grado tenemos por aquí pues
tenemos este 12 y al cuadrado y también
tenemos este al cuadrado si sumamos
estos dos tenemos doce más uno o sea 13
y al cuadrado y después todavía tenemos
que restar este menos 6
y listo aquí tenemos otra expresión para
el área del rectángulo completo ahora el
chiste de hacer todo esto es darnos
cuenta que esto de aquí y lo que tenemos
aquí abajo son equivalentes y que la
forma en la que multiplicamos a estos
dos polinomios de hecho corresponde con
la forma en la que sacamos las áreas de
todos estos rectángulos pequeños a la
hora de hacer esta multiplicación
tomamos ya al cuadrado por tres de
cuadrada y nos queda 3 a la 4 y después
multiplicamos de cuadrada por menos 2 y
nos queda menos 2 al cubo y ya cuadrada
por 1 que es cuadrada y estas 3
multiplicaciones son justo las
multiplicaciones que hicimos por aquí
para obtener las áreas de estos 3
rectángulos de la fila de arriba y
después nos pasamos a la siguiente fila
nos pasamos a menos 6 y tenemos menos 6
por 3 y al cuadrado que es menos 18 al
cubo
y menos seis por menos dos que es 12 al
cuadrado y menos 6 por 1 que es menos 6
aquí tenemos estas otras tres áreas y
como podemos observar aquí a la hora de
multiplicar dos polinomios y obtener
esto de acá no estamos simplemente
haciendo vudú
esto tiene todo el sentido del mundo
cuando lo ves a través de modelos de
áreas como aquí